what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to the
wildest title
i have seen um are white girls tainted
when they date black men by donovan
sharp
so anyone that's followed me on the
channel knows that my ex-boyfriend
was black or is black um
so we'll see how this goes i'm a little
nervous to watch this but before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell
while you're at it um go follow my
instagram the link is in the description
and it's just probably things but with
instead of an s at the end it's a z
you can send me um video requests on
there so if anyone has any videos that
they'd want to send me
send it to me on instagram
[Music]
there is a pervasive proverb among
caucasian females when referring to
dating
or hooking up with african-american men
and that
saying is once you go black you don't go
back
what this means is that once a woman has
a little fun with a black dude
she won't be interested in going back to
dating white guys or any other race of
male on account of the wild and crazy
time she had with the brother
now i'm not a white girl so i can't
speak to whether or not this is true
however i have a proverb to piggyback
off of that one which rings 256
true and my proverb is once you go black
you can't go back
allow me to explain
women are extremely influenced by
perceived social pressure
whether they admit it or not all of
their decisions from what they wear
to where they work to the cars they
drive in their minds
are heavily scrutinized by just about
everyone they know
of course this isn't really the case
sure a friend of hers might comment on
her new shoes
or the fact that she needs to find a new
job or that her boyfriend is a loser
but after that 45 second conversation
her friend isn't thinking about her
anymore
she's thinking about herself the problem
is women don't realize this
they're under the impression that
everyone around them men and women alike
are constantly judging everything they
do no i do not think that i'm sure a lot
of girls
do but it's hard because in the middle
sphere they'll always tell me that i
don't actually like i say that
but like women say things that they
don't mean but genuinely
uh whenever i get embarrassed about
something that's what i tell myself is
that they probably won't even remember
that's half that's how i do this channel
honestly is mentally
i say that if the video is that bad
people won't watch it
all the time as though they have nothing
else to do other than to watch
and talk about her all day every day
this speaks to the extreme solipsism of
the female species
more importantly it is the reason that
when they mess with black guys
a lot of them feel like they can't date
white guys anymore
in her mind if she's seen with a brother
she knows she's probably
off limits to white guys so now the
question becomes
why i don't get it why are white girls
considered to be off limits
to white guys once she messes with black
guys
why do white guys lose their freaking
minds when they find out their pretty
blonde haired blue-eyed snowflake
has been violated by a brother well the
answers are actually quite simple
but before i get to that let me quickly
remind you that if you have a question
or a comment pertaining to dating
relationships or anything else that
applies to dominating life as a man here
in the 2020s
call the tsr hotline voice mailbox at
702-919-7197
you'll get multiple perspectives
opinions and sage advice from each
panelist
i will also address questions or
comments in videos just like this one
you also need to make sure you get your
hands on my free ebook
16 ways to immediately disqualify her
for a long-term relationship
this ebook is a guide for men i need to
get it i need to get it in reaction pour
back on the dating market after a
divorce
a bad breakup or any number of
frustrating situations that led you to
this community
in the first place this book will make
it nearly why am i here
why am i here impossible for the bad
girls out there to pull you into
thinking that they're good girls
this book is absolutely free when you
sign up for my newsletter
go to donovansharp.com newsletter plug
in your very best email and the book is
yours
okay let's get back to our question why
are white women considered to be
off limits by white guys if they mess
with black guys
i answered part of this question in a
video i did a while back
discussing the racial implications of
the very first black bachelor in that
franchise's history
take a look the second uncomfortable
truth about the bachelor people are
afraid to talk about out loud
is that the white women who compete will
be considered tainted
by white men yes this is also a thing
when a white man finds out his white
wife or girlfriend had
biblical relations with a black man he
loses his mind
she's ruined he thinks but his adverse
reaction is not because of racism
at least not most of the time it's about
the adult film industry
and the media for the most part let me
explain every black male adult film
actor
without exception has an exceptionally
large
now the same could be said about their
white counterpart how does he know this
is there like a survey or something
which is why they're in the business in
the first place
but the blackmail actors have these
gargantuan
that make even the most impressive
looking white
bananas look comparatively small
if any man black or white consumes
enough adult film entertainment with
black actors
he's going to internalize this as the
norm and subconsciously assume that
every black man has a huge
add that to the fact that white men are
routinely portrayed in movies and
television as
latent or inferior beta males while
black men are portrayed as these static
alphas
i can see why some white guys might hit
the eject button
if he finds out his pretty little
fair-skinned companion has been to the
dark side
he's thinking of her being ravaged by
this hulking muscular super alpha
with an eggplant emoji the size of a
baseball bat
this is exactly why a lot of white men
will not date white women who have dated
black men
very few would admit that out loud but a
lot of them really do feel this way
so when white men watch matt james
swapping spit with pretty white women
those girls are all but discarded from
their lists
don't believe me after lindsey vonn
dated tiger woods
white guy stayed away only black men
would date her exclusively
and now she's engaged to nhl star pk
subon
yeah but how do you know that wasn't
just her type
huh who is black then i guess
i guess i'm marrying a black guy there's
amber rose
you think white guys are lining up to
date i'll be i'll be the
experiment well amber rose
isn't she half black her given her
dating history
look i don't make the rules but facts
are facts
and at the end of the day every white
contestant on matt james's season of the
bachelor
will find it very difficult to find
white men who will date or marry them
that's a difficult truth to acknowledge
for these girls but it is indeed the
truth
today's white men consistently show and
tell white women
that once they're marked as a wet and
dirty shark
which is a derogatory label assigned to
white girls who date black guys
she is then considered to be undateable
and unmarriable
now white men would never admit this out
loud or in a group
but black men are a threat to them in
terms of dating market value
yes white guys are at the top of the
dating market food chain
meaning that all things being equal most
white girls prefer white men
but conventional wisdom in their circles
is that man for men
black men are physically superior have
more game
and are much better between the sheets
than they are
whether or not this is actually true
doesn't seem to matter
but the fact of the matter is that
mainstream media portrays black males as
static alphas
who generate tingles with every
interaction they have with a woman
then like i previously discussed when
you factor in interracial adult films
into the mix where every black male
actor has an enormous sausage
which of course further perpetuates the
bbc myth
it's no wonder white dudes stay away
from white girls who have come to the
dark side even one time in their lives
so rather than admitting the truth about
their dating market options white girls
use the word
don't in place of the word can't they do
this to give themselves and the world
the impression that they know
no that's not true i don't know i've
always just like
this is my first black like boyfriend
but i've always that's always just been
my type
i don't know go back to dating white
guys if they wanted to no there was a
white guy that wanted to date me i
didn't want to date him
but no okay knowing that they probably
couldn't
if word got out about her proclivities
to commingle with brothers
here's another question is this really
about race in the first place
in short no let me give you a personal
example
if i were interested in a woman
approached her got her number and set up
a date
then listen to her swoon over her
ex-boyfriend who stood at
three percent body fat who was worth
seven figures and at a 13 inch sausage
i would not set up a second date you
want to know something
his race wouldn't matter whether this
mythical man were asian
white black or hispanic his race would
be of little or no consequence
the fact that i don't measure up
statistically to her ex is what would
keep me away
not his race today's white men live that
make-believe scenario
every time they see a good-looking white
girl holding hands with a black guy
no they can't assume what his net worth
is but if that guy's in decent shape
white guys automatically assume that he
is plowing her senseless with his
baseball bat-sized male organ
in a white guy's mind he thinks that
he'll never be able to smash her
or take her on the emotional
rollercoaster ride
my brother says
the brother appears to be doing for her
if he saw a pretty white girl with a
white guy who was tall
good-looking and self-assured he'd
probably have those same assumptions
so this scarlet letter has more to do
with the perceived persona of black men
and less with our skin tone
a while back i did a podcast called why
do parents discourage their teens from
interracial dating
in that episode i stated that if white
fathers showed their daughters what a
strong
masculine head of household was rather
than allowing themselves to be bossed
around and marginalized by their bossy
wives
their daughters would be far less likely
to date outside of their race
namely black guys another element i
pointed out
was that white fathers know that if
their white daughters had a reputation
for dating black men
or black boys in high school she would
essentially take herself out of the
running to secure a high value white
male
at least in the city or country they
live in my dad literally does not care
white fathers can say whatever they want
they can give politically correct
answers if asked in public
but deep down they know that if their
white daughters date
hook up with marry or even have a baby
with a black man
her dating options would be greatly
limited in that regard
and guess what white fathers it's okay
to feel this way
this isn't about race it's about your
daughter essentially rejecting men like
you
it's the very same reason that black
mothers lose their minds when their
black sons choose white women
trying my other brother see if he
answers
oh sorry did i wake you up
um okay can i ask you just a quick
question
it's like it's a dating question okay
does it intimidate you if you date a
girl and or you're like interested in a
girl and you find out her
ex is like better looking uh makes more
money like basically better in every way
than you
oh because guess who's here now
okay second question do you care if like
she's dated black guys before
okay that's it very racist very
racist thought
no it was a topic on the show that like
white guys won't date a girl
that um like white guy is one date a
girl she like is known for dating black
guys
so i was just wondering for you that's a
very racist
thing yeah no i agree i was just
wondering
reagan has a black axe and um
uh think katie had a black ex-boyfriend
too
but not actually sure on the second one
okay okay thanks i'm gonna finish my
video
hell even i can admit that if i had a
daughter i'd feel some type of way if
she chose to be with a white guy
does that make me a racist no it makes
me a human being
the once you go black trope is the
quintessential example of women not
acknowledging the truth about their
status in the dating market that they
are ever labeled as the
white girl who dates black dudes and
that truth is that once she is labeled
as such
short of moving to another state and
starting anew with new friends
erasing all facebook or other social
media pictures she will be all but
invisible to white men and i would agree
with this assertion
white girls can act like they have the
option to go back
if they chose to by proudly proclaiming
they won't
but i've always said that women are far
more aware of the truth regarding
intersexual dynamics than men will ever
be
and it is for this reason alone that
they understand very clearly that once
they go black
they can't go back so white guys am i
wrong about you guys staying away from
white girls if they've messed with black
guys
or are you going to admit the truth and
white girl this is the thing i hate
about the man of spirit
like they are the keepers of truth they
know all the answers
what extents do you guys go to to cover
up your dark side escapades i'd be very
interested to find out
and don't forget if you want sometimes
the manosphere is weird
um if a white if a white dude and a
woman
live in the same community and everyone
in their circle knows she has a history
of black
dudes that's going to be that's not
going to be any relationship the white's
dudes will probably smash but that's it
if they live in a large city or move out
of town and no one knows it won't be
as big of a deal but it's wise for the
woman to keep quiet
about that history if she wants a
relationship
um in-group preferences all over the
world that isn't unique to black white
um okay
well after watching a few of kevin
samuels podcasts and seeing the woman
oh um the history of saying want to go
black
was intended to serve as a warning to a
white woman who would
befall them and should opt for the
chocolate doing their us just
ostracized for from respectable society
and all of its benefits noticed
this was never said or directed or
forced when white men got with black
women
i'd be interested to see like the actual
data on this
um i would guess that's probably more
prevalent than like the older generation
because most of the people he was like
mentioning are a little bit older but
even like me
um and maybe half them atmosphere never
believed me but there was a white guy
who definitely wanted to date me
um and he like knew
i'd like dated a black guy before um
and then i'm sorry i'm just thinking
but i don't know i don't really care i
just date people i like
anyways let me know in the comments if
you guys agree or disagree this is an
interesting video don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell and i will talk to you
guys
next time